governor bateman in california governor
gavin newsom mr nussolini
is also getting in on the act is it time
governor to bring
back a universal mass mandate
regardless of vaccination status there
in california
look we don't even have to have that
debate if we can just get everybody
vaccinated that's not vaccinated that's
refusing to get vaccinated this living
vaccine free and impacting the rest of
us it's like drunk drivers you don't
have the right to go out and drink and
drive and put everybody else at risk
including your own life at risk
what's funny about this explanation that
he's giving this analogy that he's
making
is how stuffy he sounds does bateman
does governor bateman have the
coronavirus he
i don't know you're hearing a lot of
stories now about huge numbers of people
who were vaccinated now getting
the virus anyway i personally know
people who got vaccinated and then they
just get the virus anyway
but you have to get it because it's very
very important even though it doesn't
work so you gotta
wear the mask anyway and we'll keep you
posted on what the science says tomorrow
what uh governor newsom is saying that's
right newsom that's his name
what he's saying is that if you do not
receive the experimental drug
for the virus that poses a very very low
threat to a lot of people
then it's basically like you're drunk
driving and you and the point he's
making is that there
are you know externalities to your
behavior when you're talking about
health this is kind of the premise of
public health
and so the state has a right to go in
and enforce certain health measures and
i actually agree with that in principle
i think a lot of conservatives would
agree with that in principle you hear
all of these comparisons being made to
the
to smallpox or polio or to the bubonic
plague for goodness sakes
the issue is not so much the principle
as it is the particular because the
woofloo
is not bubonic plague the wufou wuflu is
not polio
and by the way the public health
professionals and the politicians
who have been ordering us around for the
past year and a half
have gotten a lot of things gotten most
things wrong
the issue here is the particulars does
the state
have credibility to order me to take
this experimental drug
now for a virus that poses a very very
infinitesimally small risk
to huge numbers of people it poses a
greater risk to some people
but to most people very low risk hey
i'm glad you like that clip seriously
i'm very glad that
pleases me greatly i would be even
happier if you would watch the whole
show
it is called an offer you can't refuse
go check it out it's here on youtube
it's on apple podcast spotify stitcher
google play myspace xanga live journal
hotmail
linux i don't know it's everywhere go
get it subscribe and by the way you can
still order my number one national
bestselling book
speechless controlling words controlling
mind see you next time